hey welcome to an asp.net crash course
in this video in about an hour we're
going to build a complete website that
has a database application
written in the c-sharp language
so here's what the application is going
to look like we're going to build a
jokes app
and this will allow you to enter in
jokes and their answers
so that you can keep a record of all
your best humor
this application is a basic crud
application
so crud refers to create read update and
delete from a database
so we'll create all the forms the
website and the database that makes it
all happen
in the database we'll be able to search
for the jokes that we create
and we'll see the tables and all of the
forms that go with them my name is chad
sluter i'm a professor of computer
science and software development
at grand canyon university in phoenix
i'm really glad to be here at free code
camp
and provide another resource for you i
endorse free code camp
i've used it in my classroom i've used
it personally it's a great way to become
smarter in many things so the goal of my
career is to make you a software
developer
and free code camp is a great resource
so let's get started here with the next
lesson
let's talk about this course and see
what's in it for you
we'll talk about what is asp.net core
we're going to talk about what means the
model view controller design
pattern we'll set up a database we'll do
registration
login and page security and then do some
database querying
so all of these things are what's ahead
so let's talk about whether this course
is
right for you it's going to take you
about an hour of video time but
it is really an intermediate level
course there are some things that you
should know
beforehand when i teach this course it's
usually the third one
in a series on the c-sharp language
previous experience with object-oriented
programming
is probably something that you should
already have we're working with a
framework
asp.net is a framework using c sharp
so you should understand the language
before you try to build a framework
frameworks are somewhat complex you
should have experience in setting up
databases you should know what a table
is
you should look at some sql queries and
know what they are
and be able to design them lastly we're
going to work with html and css
and javascript so you should know
something about building web pages
already
so if this looks good for you let's
continue on so what is asp.net core and
why would you want to use it
well microsoft developed c-sharp and
this framework to build web applications
and so if you want to build a website
with a database then this is a good tool
to use
there are competitors out there of
course you can build framework
applications in java
using spring php laravel
python the language python with flask
you could work with javascript with
nodejs and express
so all of these are similar solutions
and this is a popular one asp.net will
get you a real job
at corporations that create enterprise
level
applications many students that i've
taught before
have well-paying jobs in large companies
using this exact technology
dot net is microsoft's solution to
develop
software of all kinds since about 2001.
it's very similar to what you would know
if you work with java in the java
virtual machine
it's a runtime environment that you can
create applications for on multiple
platforms
asp stands for active server
pages it's kind of a leftover term from
earlier technologies in the early 2000s
but they still keep asp in the name
the word core is somewhat new to
microsoft
core is the open source version of their
web development kit
it's cross-platform you can run your
applications now on any server whether
it's linux
you can write your applications in linux
or mac
or or windows so core is microsoft's
open source cross-platform solution to
developing software
dot net is their unified platform to
build almost
anything in software land desktop
applications
web applications hosting on the cloud
creating apps in mobile
gaming internet of things artificial
intelligence
microsoft is a very powerful player in
software development and
net is their solution so in this course
we're going to focus on asp.net which is
used for building
web applications how does c-sharp fit
into this
well net is not the language that we're
talking about
c sharp is one language that is used in
this platform
so the dot net framework consists of a
runtime engine and
libraries for executing programs in a
compliant language so c
sharp is one language it is by far the
most popular language but you could
write it in other things as well
but we're going to use c-sharp because
that is microsoft's premier tool
and their language of preference for
this kind of work
so why do we need asp.net and why did
microsoft invent it
well about 97 there was this change from
desktop centric computing
to web centric computing so microsoft
was firmly in control
with their win forms and clients on
their pcs
and then the internet happened and so we
went from building
form-based applications to web-based
applications and asp
was their solution so net is very
similar to java in many ways
as you might know java was written as a
language that could be
written on one platform and executed on
any platform
and so they had a java virtual machine
well microsoft created.net
pretty much an answer to that so asp was
somewhat similar to
what you would see today in php it's an
it's a language that runs a dynamic
website
the net part is similar to java that
it's compiled on one platform and can
run on many platforms
so you combine the two and you have an
active server pages
and net as the compiled environment and
so asp.net
is their answer to making web pages on a
web server
so here's what an asp page looks like
you can see that there's some code here
that is a mixture of html
and something that looks like c sharp
and so we would call this
razor this is their markup language that
is able to
create something that is dynamic so
every time you
click on an item in a web page you get a
custom version
just for that user so probably hooking
up to a database
and showing information in a dynamic
option so this platform
is a end-to-end solution it runs the
back end
and the front end and so we'll call it a
full stack environment
so you have a database management system
you have business logic in the middle
and the front end with html it also can
be combined with popular front-end
services so if you're into javascript
programming such as react
angular or vue or mobile applications
that could be your front end and you
could learn your asp.net tools
to manage the database in the back end
so it's your choice
you can choose the front end and the
back end you can use them all together
or separately so it's a very flexible
programming
environment let's go ahead and start
building an application
in asp.net core all right well let's get
started on the next section in our
course outline
we're going to focus on this line here
called model views and controllers or
mvc and so we'll actually build an
application that you can test
what you see in front of you is the
finished application
it's called the jokes app let's go ahead
and look at some of the features
so first of all i click the link called
jokes and you can see that all the jokes
that i've put into my database appear
let's try the first one why did the
chicken cross the road
let's click the details link and of
course the answer is
to get to the other side if we want to
change this we can click the edit button
and then we're asked to log in so i put
in my username and password
i can log in so instead of crosstheroad
let's try the word playground
have you heard this one why did the
chicken cross the playground
well the answer is to get to the other
slide
instead of side let's save that and now
you can see the results
should show up in the list so now you
can see the question is now why did the
chicken cross the playground so if you
wanted to see the answer you could click
details
or if you wanted to delete or edit it
you could do that let's try the search
function
and so if i wanted to put in a joke here
about jump let's see if we get anything
search comes up so now you can see one
joke in the search results
can a kangaroo jump higher than the
empire state building and wait for it
the answer is
of course the empire state building
can't jump
let's go ahead and back to the list and
that one's so bad
i'm going to just delete it right now
and yes it is
gone all right so that's the application
we're going to build
let's get started with a new project and
i'll show you how to create these forms
in an automatic fashion so you have to
have your computer set up to work
properly to run this stuff
i'm using visual studio on a windows 10
computer now there are other ways that
you can set this up
but this is by far the simplest i'm
going to go ahead and create a new
project
and and choose from the list so there
are lots of things that you can develop
with visual studio i'm going to select
some things like c sharp all platforms
such as
windows and i'm going to choose web as
my choice that narrows down
some of the things that i can build the
item that i'm searching for is called
asp.net core web application
as you can see there are dozens of
different types of projects that you can
build
and so what you're learning here is just
a crash course
of what visual studio can do but let's
get started
with this version right here and choose
next so i'm going to name mine as
jokes web app you can see the location
is set to a
directory on my hard drive you can
change this if you want or leave it as
the default
and click create once you choose the web
application you can see there are many
different choices on how you're going to
build it
so i'm going to select the traditional
right here it's called web application
model view controller and that is the
full stack solution you can see there
are other options
such as if you want to use angular or
react for your front end
and if you want to choose an empty thing
that you can just build from scratch
you can choose that i'm choosing this
one here because
a lot of code is automatically generated
for me
it's the fastest way to get started now
over here i'm going to change the
authentication option
right now there is no authentication
which means there are no databases
no user accounts i'm going to switch
that because i want the computer to
generate as much as it can
for me and so that i can get started
quickly
now i'm going to also select individual
user accounts
so that will create the database and it
will set up tables for me
now if you work with an enterprise
authentication system you might want to
select one of these other ones but the
individual accounts is very very
common let's go ahead and choose ok
now you should see that this option is
checked we have
configured like this on the other side
and
let's go ahead and choose create now
now what we're creating is a predefined
system that's going to have a lot of
code
generated for us so let's take a look
around and see what asp.net generated
for us
first of all if you're familiar with
visual studio this will be
similar to projects that you've done
before we have a solution explorer
it shows us all of the code that's been
generated for us
and don't worry we're going to look in
each of these folders as we go through
the tutorial
and you'll learn what they do you can
see on the other side here we have a sql
server object explorer
and it says we have a sql server up and
running so that's all built into visual
studio
when you get started now if you don't
see any of these things you can go to
the view menu
and you can find all of these things on
the
choices here so you can show them or
hide them
under the view menu at the center you
can see that there's a welcome page
and the dotnet core documentation is
something we're going to be looking at
so this will bring you to microsoft's
official website
if you're done with your application you
can connect it and host this application
on azure which is microsoft's cloud
platform
we're not going to get to that but if
you wanted to you could extend your
application to run online
ours is going to be a local solution so
we will be serving it on a local host
or a local web server which will only be
used
by you the programmer for right now i'm
going to
close this and then i'm just going to
start by clicking the green button that
says
iis express that stands for information
internet
server it's microsoft's web server and
it will automatically
launch and compile everything that we
see in the solution explorer
so you can see that my application
already launched
a web browser pops up i'm using chrome
as my default browser and so that's why
you see chrome here
and you can see the web service is now
starting at
localhost so there's a web server
installed on this windows machine
and it tells me i'm running on this port
number and then i have
joke's web app open so there are two
pages that are automatically designed
for you
the home page and the privacy page
there's a registration and login page
that is already set up for you now we're
going to close the app because it really
doesn't do much more than show two pages
let's look around and see where those
things are coming from
so let's look in the folders here on the
jokes web app solution
so we have important parts here called
controllers
and views now if you look inside of the
home
view you're going to see an index page
let's open that
and you can see that we have the welcome
message that appears
on our website let's look at privacy
and you can see that there is another
web page
so the views area is probably the
easiest to understand for a new
programmer these are html pages
however they are labeled as cs
html so that is c sharp
html it's the combination of two
languages blended into
one page let's start off by modifying
the privacy page
so it says use this page to detail your
site's
privacy let's also modify the index page
here
which is the welcome screen so i'm going
to modify the
h1 tag which is the big welcome sign
and then inside the paragraph tag i'm
going to change the sentence to
something
that makes sense for my application so
let's see if those two changes will
occur
on our website
so i click the green arrow for run and
you should see
new pages appear so you can see the new
page shows up
the jokes application and i click
privacy and i get the next message that
i just created
so that's what a view is it's a website
and it's the html code that you can
modify
so now we're going to get into this
concept of mvc models views and
controllers
we've just looked at what a view is a
view is a web page using
html or in this syntax we're going to
call it razer
we're going to next look at what a model
is and what a controller is
and how they run so mvc is really a
design pattern
it's not a language the point here is to
create
applications that have separations of
concerns
that means your file sizes are smaller
your code is modular
and it can be run and managed by
multiple people
so there are three parts to an mvc first
of all there's a model
that's a class and so we'll be creating
a model for our
joke a joke will have a question an
answer and an id number
we're also going to create views we just
looked at what a view is it's a web page
and then the most important part perhaps
is the central
controller so the control the controller
handles the logic of a
of the computer code it tells the pages
when to appear
it gives them data that they can show
and so that's what a model view
controller is
let's talk about what a website looks
like using this system
so the user first of all has a request
it says
give me all the orders of today's date
and
the system that you see here this
asp.net
would interpret that through a router so
a router would look at the url
and say hey today we're going to look at
our date and we are looking for the
orders
it would send this information then to
the controller of your program
the controller says hey i'm going to see
that you're looking at the route
called orders and it has a specific url
well then it says i'm going to create a
list of all the orders
and so it would have a c sharp language
that says
let's create a list and let's go to the
store and get the orders for today
well that would have to hit the database
and so we're going to see
sql statements then that says hey let's
get all of the orders where the date
equals today it will return that to the
model
the model will send it to the controller
the controller now has
a list of data what's the controller
going to do with that data
well it's going to then send it off to a
view and to say
hey show me the show orders.html page
and here is a list of data that goes
with it well then
it's going to generate a list that is
going to be an
html format and send it to the browser
and so when it gets back to the user you
have a fully formed web page
so all of these things in the background
are called
every time you click something on a
website
generating a dynamically produced page
that would show you today's orders so
let's return into our program and see
where those things are
so we've already looked at views let's
look at the controller next
so if i go into controllers there's a
page called home controller
you can see that there are functions in
this controller that says things like
index so index says return me a
view and there's nothing in here to tell
us which view it is
and so the index page is assumed here
scrolling down a little bit further we
come to another event called
privacy so if the controller says the
person clicked on the privacy
link send them the link called view
which is also privacy
here is another event called error and
if the error occurs that means the user
clicked on some link that doesn't exist
so let's go ahead and start creating
some views and
we'll see how this controller then is
able to work
hi in this section of the tutorial we're
going to create some views
so remember that a view is a piece of
html code
or something similar it usually gets its
information
from a list of data from the controller
we're going to dynamically create this
page
in using c-sharp and the html language
that language we're going to call razer
the other part of the page is going to
be a model and so we're going to be
creating a model for our joke
a model is always data related it
consists
of classes or objects with properties
the model will usually be supplied by
the controller
and sent to the view with a list of
objects and so let's see what that looks
like
in code so returning again to our
project here let's open the project
called
models now there is something called an
error view model
but we're not going to look at that
because i just want to start with the
simplest
model we can so let's do a right click
on this folder
and let's choose add and i'm going down
to the
option called class so inside the model
folder
add class now i'm going to remain
selected with the item called class and
then
for the name i'm going to call it joke
so a joke
is the class and it's going to be the
central part of our application
go ahead and click add so this is the
object oriented part of the code
so a class or an object is going to have
properties
now in c-sharp you can create a property
with this shortcut
prop press the tab key twice
and you will get a piece of code that's
automatically generated
so the class is going to be this
property is going to have a
public accessibility and the integer is
the data type i'm going to press tab one
more
and i'm going to use id as the property
number
in c sharp for a getter and setter you
just put in
the parentheses here and the word get
and set
so that is the default type of project
property
for our joke let's create two more items
i'm going to have a joke question
and a joke answer so this is a very
simple version of a class or an object
let's save it and now we're going to
create some things to go with it
the last property that i'm going to
create is actually a method it's going
to be a constructor
so there's a shortcut in c sharp where
you can type in ctor
type tab tab and it will automatically
generate the function called the
constructor
now for right now i'm just going to
leave the constructor empty because
it's going to be used by other pieces of
the code and it needs to be empty like
this
the next thing we're going to do is
create some pages dynamically the system
is going to generate them for us
but we need to know that there is a file
here that was already in the system
it's called the application db context
so you don't have to worry about what is
in it for right now but you do need to
know it's there
because it's going to ask for this in
just a moment
the next step is going to generate a lot
of code for us
let's right click on the controllers
area choose
add and controller now the controller
is going to be the heart of this thing
but it's going to create a lot of other
pieces as well
so we need to select the right kind of
controller so i'm going to choose the
third one down i think it is that has
all of the options such as
we're going to create all of the things
to do create add delete and edit
then we're going to select the model
the model that we're choosing is this
jokes class
and so it'll create these pages based on
the properties of our joke
the other part that i've warned you
about it's going to ask you for this
application
db context we'll get to what that is in
a minute but we just need to supply it
here
make sure that your check marks at the
bottom match mine that will generate the
html code as a partial page
so that it'll fit into the website very
nicely finally click the create button
now this is going to take a while you'll
see things that will install
automatically
and if all goes well we will see several
new pages
that will be shown on our website
automatically
okay finally this is done it took me
several minutes for the generation to
occur
but we now have this jokes controller
here
and we should also see that in the views
folder we have a new folder called
jokes and so you can see that there are
five new web pages that were created
there is create delete details edit
and index so hours of programming have
just been done for you
with a single click of the mouse now
we're interested to see if this works so
let's go ahead and run the application
well it looks like the application's up
and running we still have home and
privacy as our two links
but what about the jokes controller we
just created it
well you can see that the url is about
home right now well that's the home
controller that's in action so let's
delete the
home privacy part and just type in the
word jokes
what do we get we should see a new page
that shows all of the jokes in our
database
well we have a problem because we don't
have a database yet
so it says uh the database operation
failed and so we have some work to do
with the database
but the pages should be there so in the
next section of the tutorial we're going
to create the database
so that those jokes pages will come to
life
in this section of the tutorial we're
going to take our model that we've built
and we're actually going to create the
database that goes behind it
and so we'll use something called
migrations to create our tables
let's look at our project to see a new
section that we haven't done anything
with yet
there's a folder called data and you can
see that there is another folder called
migrations in here let's go see what
this is all about so if i click on here
you're going to see some code that is
about databases
you can see that we're generating a
table called asp.net roles
you can see that there's going to be
another table called users
there's also a class in our project
called joke
and i don't see anything about jokes
tables so we're going to fix that right
now
now down at the bottom of the screen
here there's an area that is called the
output
and i'm going to switch to the package
manager console
now the goal of the package manager
console is usually to install
new dependencies however we're going to
use it for some database management
so in this console i'm going to attempt
to type
enable hyphen migrations
and you can see that there's a message
that says hey you're looking at an older
version of this
so old guys have to learn new tricks
we're going to now type in the word
add migration so add hyphen migration
and then we have to give it a name
and so the first migration is the
initial setup of our database
so that's what i'll call it you can name
it any string you want but it has to be
something descriptive
okay so something happens after i type
this in
let's see what the computer generated
back into the migrations folder you'll
see a
new file called initial setup exactly
named as what i just created
let's see what's inside here so there is
a command
called create table joke and let's see
what else there is
it looks to me like that's the only item
so we're going to create
a new table you can see that the joke is
supposed to have a joke question
and a joke answer so what we've just
started is something called an object
relation mapper you can see that the
mapping here is between a class and a
table
so in this example the class on the
right is a person
it has an id name phone and age for
properties
and the orm is creating a table for us
which is going to match exactly to that
class
an orm then is an object relation mapper
now there are two options for creating
databases with a system like this
the object relational map or orm is a
popular
tool but it's not the only way to do it
the more traditional
way is called a dao where you create
your tables manually
and then you are more traditionally
managing your database
access you write your own sql statements
with this
and here's the catch that most people
that manage databases like the dbas in
your company
they usually prefer the old-fashioned
method the reason why is because
they can get more visibility on what's
happening in the database
not so automated however the orms on the
other hand
are sometimes preferred by programmers
that are trying to save some time
it allows the computers to generate data
tables without you having to actually
write any sql statements
so an orm has been called a way for
people to write sql statements
without writing sql statements it's a
shortcut
you can use your database tools to be
updated
using what's called migrations which is
right is where we're in the process
right now of coding
so entity is the name of the orm
that we're using right now it's
microsoft's orm
orms are very good for simple
applications
such as our jokes app however another
version of this tutorial should include
how to make daos or data access objects
because a lot of companies would prefer
you to use that kind of a system
when you build your app so now let's
return to visual studio
and maybe we can understand what this is
doing now
so this folder called migrations is the
language of
creating tables now all we have to do to
make this happen is type in the word
update
hyphen database and i'll press enter
and i'll let the orm do the magic of
creating all the tables for us
so it's going to create two tables one
is for the user accounts
the second is for our jokes it'll
probably have more tables than that but
that's the basic idea okay
i see a message that says done let's go
look in our folders to see what happened
so i'm going over to the left side that
says the sql object explorer
if you can't see that you can go to the
view menu and get it
now i'm going to open up the sql server
and it has two different projects here
two different databases let's see what
they are i'm going to open the first one
and i search for databases and it looks
to me like we have several of them so
i'm going to choose
the jokes web app is what i'm interested
in let's
open that up and then finally tables
so inside the tables area you can see
that there are several tables that are
all about users
and then one about jokes well i think we
could understand the one about jokes the
best so let's double click joke
and see what it looks like so as i open
up the definition you can see that the
table has been created according to the
properties of my joke
so it has id joke question and joke
answer
integer string and string and all of
that was created for me without me
knowing
anything about sql so the application
is apparently got a database let's see
if it'll work now so i'm going to push
the green arrow again to run the
application
all right so we got the app up and
running and if i click on one of these
things you can see it'll still work on
these pages
now we don't have any links that are
automatically taking us to the jokes
controller so i'll have to type in
jokes as my url and press enter
now earlier we had a message that says
your database was not configured however
now we have an index page
so this shows me all of the jokes that
are in my database
obviously i don't have any yet so let's
click the create new button
and it says make me a new joke well
let's see it looks to me like i've put
some in before so let's try why the
chicken cross the road
and the answer is to get to the other
side
so those are typed in let's click the
create button
and now we've got ourselves an index
page
so do we want to delete the joke edit or
show the details
we can do all of those things so each
one of these pages has
already been created for us
automatically the database is in the
background
so you could say hey we're done with our
jokes app not so fast
there's a bunch of more features that
we're going to add but you have reached
the point where you have a
functioning application that you created
with just a few mouse clicks
now some of the features that i'd like
to add such as details i would like to
show
who the owner was we're going to log in
and register
and link those together we're also going
to not give away the answers so right
now we've got
the joke question here and the joke
answer on the same page that's kind of a
giveaway
so we'll fix that we're also going to
limit the
access so if i click the create button
and i'm not logged in
it will not allow me to click a create
button so those are some of the things
that we're going to improve
in the next few videos hey so now let's
take a look
toward the end of the course here what i
have on the screen is a finished product
of all the features that we're going to
add
so you can see that i've created a
couple of menu items up here first of
all the jokes
choice so now we see a list of all the
jokes that are in the database
also we have a search function so if we
want to find something such as the word
jump and search we would find an answer
it looks like i don't have that jokes
question anymore also if i try the
create new button
you can see that now we are forced to
log in
so no anonymous jokes are allowed here
if i choose log
in then i can add a new joke and you can
see it's associated with a user id when
i create it
okay back to our current progress here
i've kind of rewound now my application
to where we left off just a minute ago
the first thing i want to do is add the
link at the top of our
menu so we want to show the jokes list
as a item that we can click on to do
that we need to go into this folder here
inside of views
called shared and then we have a item
called layout
let's go check that out and see what's
in there so as you look through the
layout code you'll see that it looks
like a bunch of html
now this item here is the nav bar that's
what we're going to
add a item to now if you were to know
bootstrap then you're all set to go
because bootstrap
classes are what you see all the way
through here so this is css programming
if you haven't done a tutorial on that
probably this is going to look strange
but
anyway let's take a look at the code
right here in this
section so this is one of the items in
the nav bar
you can see that it is the privacy link
and there's another link above it called
the
home link so we don't have to understand
all of the classes and all of the items
in here but we can just modify one so
i'm going to
copy this and then press enter and paste
so now i have three links and the link
called privacy is duplicated
so let's see if we can modify this to
work correctly
so first of all a link has an a tag and
the item in between
is the text so let's just put in jokes
now the other item here are some of
these
asp tags so it says asp controller
so the controller name well the home
controller
is what the first two links are we
created a
jokes controller either earlier so let's
type in the word jokes
and then it says what's the action the
action on this guy is
index now how did i know how to do those
things let's go look at the controller
and see where that information comes
from
so i scroll to the top of the screen and
i find the jokes controller
so we'll look at this and then come back
to our nav bar in a second
so the jokes controller the joke's
controller
is going to have a few methods in it
first of all
the index method here is the item that
is going to
show all jokes and you can see that it
is already got some code inside here
so this is database code that was
created
using the entity framework
so let's go back to our uh our code here
in the layout
so what did i put in here i put in the
word jokes
why didn't i put the whole word jokes
controller
well the word controller is assumed so
if you type in
joke's controller that would probably
make more sense
at least in my mind but that's not the
way that microsoft designed it so
jokes is the only thing we need to put
then the
index is the action so let's save this
and run it and test it out
okay looks like the app is up and
running and you can see that in the menu
we have now a jokes item so if i click
here we should bring up the jokes list
and sure enough there it is so this is
the index page for the jokes controller
and if we want we can go to the other
items from here so now instead of having
to learn how to type in the url
up there with the jokes we have a link
to it in our nav bar
so there's one nice feature done let's
now add the search function
and then we'll add the new list in our
in our page
all right so here's the next item so i'm
going to copy and paste
another link so let's change the text
here
to the word search and i'm going to then
change the action to something else so
we're still in the jokes controller
but now the action i'm going to call it
show
search form how about and that doesn't
exist yet in the controller so we need
to go
fix that just to show you how this works
let's run it and see what happens
so the app is up and running we can go
ahead and look at the jokes list
and we should see the one item in our
search now let's click the search
item and you can see that we have a not
found error
so the jokes method called show
search form does not yet exist the jokes
controller does
so we need to create this method and
then make it search for our jokes
so where are we going to put that method
well it has to be in the jokes
controller so let's double click on
jokes controller
and take a look at our index this is our
model that we're going to copy and paste
so i'm going to copy
our index page and paste it and let's uh
do this let's do show search form so
that's just in the comments that says
if somebody types in this url this is
the command that's going to happen
now the key difference here that instead
of the index method we're going to type
in
show search form now all this is going
to do is show a form
and then we'll have to put in some
information there
so now we're ready for the next part it
says return a view
now i'm not going to send this view any
information so it's just an
empty view now you have two options here
now inside these parentheses we could
put in this string called
show search form that would mean go find
the form with that name
but since the method name up here is
already that
title we can just have nothing in the
view item so that is an
optional parameter all right so does
that solve our problem
i doubt it but let's run the application
and see what happens
so we're going to get a different error
this time when i click search
we're going to have a problem now that
says no longer is it not found
but we have a different problem it says
here
the view show search form
was not found so we did get to the
controller
and it says hey you wanted to show this
form there is no form yet
by that name so it says i tried to look
in all of these folders and didn't find
it
anywhere so obviously we haven't created
it yet so that's why we have this error
so i ran it here just to show you that
this is a common thing if you're
building an app and you forget to put in
a piece
okay so how we're going to create this
new form well we could go
down to the views folder and create a
folder or create an item called
show search form that would work so
since i'm lazy i'm going to let the
computer do some of the coding for me so
i'm going to right click on show
search form and the first item that
comes up is
add view well that sounds handy let's
try that
then the next screen asks a question
what kind of view do you want
do you want an empty one or do you want
to take one that's pre-programmed
i like the pre-programmed idea because
it will make a lot of code for us
so what's the form name well they
already provided is a suggestion
show search form that sounds like it now
there's a template it says what kind of
template do you want
so we could have a template that says do
you want to create something
delete an item show the details edit
empty or show a list well
we just want a data input form somewhere
where we can put in a search term and
then click the button
so the closest one to that is create so
even though we're not creating an item
we are creating a data entry form so i'm
choosing create
now what are we going to create well i
want to show
the joke model here as my basis
for creating an item i'm going to check
partial view because i want it to be
part of the main template
and then click add now isn't that nice
we just generated an
entire data input form and it's based on
the
joke answer and joke question so we
could
probably run the app now and get
something
all right so we got the app up and
running let's try the search button and
hopefully get something
there it is we have the create form here
so we have id
joe question joke answer as the input
form that's not exactly the way i want
it but
at least we have a form that is up and
running
now we're going to go back and modify
several things here
so i only want one box for my data entry
so i can knock out the
first two items that are form groups
where it says we have an input and a
label and a span
so let's just take those and delete them
so now we just have something called
joke answer and then we have a submit
button
the submit button says create so i'm
just going to change that right now to
the word
search and i'm going to change a few of
these items
so actually i don't care about jokes at
all i just use this as a template so i'm
going to knock out this item
on number one called model because we
are not creating a new joke we are just
having a data entry form
so that goes out and then for the title
i'm going to say search for a joke
at the bottom here's some more code that
is for data validation to see if you
typed in the joke in the correct format
well that's no longer needed either so
that goes away
so as soon as we take out the line for
model you can see we start getting
errors in the center of our form
that says hey you wanted to associate
this input with a
joke answer i have no idea what a joke
answer is anymore because that line on
the top of the form told me that the
model on this page
was a joke and there's no jokes anymore
now i'm going to modify the two lines
that are input and label
so no longer are we going to worry about
the
the the joke model so we're just going
to say that this
input has a name so the name of this
input is called search phrase
see how we're modifying an existing form
and
modifying it to a regular html form the
label then has to match it as well so
the label
is for the search phrase now there's
also a line here that says validation
which we don't have to worry about so
that goes away
looks like here's a line about
validation as well so we're knocking
that out
okay our form is getting really simple
now
now there is one item here that makes
something completely
wrong it says the form action the form
action right now is to
show the search form well we don't want
the search form to show itself
we want it to go to another item so now
i'm going to refer to another method
that doesn't exist yet
and we're going to call it show search
results
so show the form brings us to this form
when we enter a
item into the form we should show the
results as the next step so that's why i
called that thing the asp
action all right it's time to test it
out let's run it and see what it looks
like
alright the app is up and running let's
click the search button
and we have a simple form now it says
search for a joke
so let's search for a joke and let's
look for chicken and choose search
now we have another issue that says show
search results doesn't exist
so guess what we're going to have to do
next we're going to have to go into the
controller
and create that method so we're looking
for the jokes controller
and then the method called show search
results
that's the pattern that we're following
here so let's create that next
so to make this method occur we have to
go find the controller
so we come up here to the top and i'm
going to open up the jokes controller
again
so we did show search form as our last
guy let's take a copy and paste on this
and we're going to use him as a model
now this is going to be using
a post submit method
and then this is called show search
results so this is just comments to let
me know what i'm supposed to be making
so show search results is my method now
the data input form that we put together
just a second ago
has some values that we want to receive
here so
string i think it was called search term
and that should come directly from the
form now i'm going to verify that i
spelled that right so i'm going to go
back to the form here
and check it out so it's called search
phrase
i think i spelled that wrong so let's
copy this and come back
into the jokes controller and instead of
search term
we make sure that it matches with search
phrase okay so that's a common mistake
that i make as i don't
match up the input values that come from
our
forms and that just causes all kinds of
problems when you run the app
so at this point it should capture the
search phrase and then we're going to
have to create another view
now i want to test this out and i'm
going to change a few things around here
so that it'll just print a message to
the screen without trying to create an
entire form
so what i'd like to try next is instead
of returning an entire view like an
entire web page
i'm just going to return a string so
let's erase this part and say you
entered
and then the search phrase is what we're
going to put in there so it's just going
to echo it back to the user
now as soon as i do that you see you
have a red line that says
you're trying to convert a string which
is what i just typed
into something called an i action result
now up until this time we've just been
glossing over this section here
so this method returns an item called
task
and i action result so there's a whole
bunch of things that can be returned
when you create these views up until now
we've just created
html pages to show to the screen in more
advanced versions of this application we
could create a rest api
a service that would create json data
and that would be also
one of these i action results but for
right now i'm just trying to return a
string for testing purposes so i'm going
to knock out all of this stuff here and
just type in the word
string so that's the data type that
should be returned
and that's what i returned just below
here so this is just for testing
purposes as you'll see it's just a very
simple message
okay let's see what it looks like let's
run the app we'll do a search
and i'm going to type in something here
let's try chicken again and search
and now i get the message a string only
that says
you entered chicken so obviously strings
are
returnable and they can be displayed in
a browser but that's not really very
pretty
but it does tell me this one thing that
the form data was entered
and received by the controller and then
sent to the next item on the page
so i must have spelled all the things
correctly in my form
okay so i stopped the program and i
returned back to here so i'm going to
press ctrl
z to undo this first item control z
to enter back to where i was before
let's see i don't want that one i want
search phrase
okay so i want to get back to the stage
where i was before
so now instead of doing a view for
just a string i want to return a list of
filtered results
now if i wanted to return the entire
list i have a pattern of code that i
could use for that
that was the original index method so
i'm going up to copy
the entire list and put it into my
search results so this is not really
good search results it shows every
joke in my database but we can modify
this in just a jiffy here
so the await command says that we're
going to do some
asynchronous programming and then the
view says we're going to show
something called search results that
won't work
we need to tell it as different view so
you can put in an optional parameter at
the beginning and tell it
we're looking for the index view and the
following data to go with it
so let's see if that does anything let's
run it
okay here we are yet again let's run the
app let's do search
and let's search for a joke so if i
typed in chicken and search
i should get just chicken right so many
anything with chicken in it let's see if
it works
so it appears that i get search results
i got an answer that says chicken
let's go back and search for something
else is there any joke with the word
frog in it let's try that search
and i got the same exact results that
means that every item in my database is
being shown well i only have one item
but
anyway frog is not here so i have a
list that is returned but i need to
filter that list so that i could only
show chicken or
frog as a keyword so
to turn this into a search function
we're going to go to this
item where it has the context dot joke
and the place where we're getting our
data
so we're inserting the word where
so this is like a sql filter you know
where you can specify
a condition about how you want to select
items
so the where is going to be a
parenthesis
now inside the parentheses we are going
to use an anonymous functions
or an arrow function so that's a whole
subject in itself
of how these work so don't have time
here in a crash course to look at it but
if you want to look for arrow functions
or anonymous functions this will give
you the idea
but you can see what's happening it says
here for every j
that has a joke question that contains
the search phrase
such as frog we will put it in the list
so obviously we don't frog to be our
search all the time so i'm going to
change that to the word
search phrase and so this will filter
the list
and limit it to only the items that
contain
the search term
so let's test it out let's run the app
and search so i'm going to search for
chicken
and see what comes up and hopefully we
get results
so we did find a chicken let's search
again and this time i'm going to search
for frogs
and no frogs so if you want to create
more jokes and test out the search
app i think it'll work so that brings us
to the end of searching which was a kind
of a more advanced topic
now we're going to work with let login
and registration and then we will
assign each joke and owner hey let's do
another feature for this application
so you can see that i have a few more
jokes in my database what i'd like to do
now
is to hide this column here so joke
answer
is given in column two and to me that
gives the item away so we need to have
the user click on the details to see the
joke
punch line so this part of the tutorial
will teach you a bit about the razer
syntax and building these views
so the view that i'm looking for is the
one that shows
all of the jokes so i'm going into the
jokes folder
and the index page is the one i want now
let's diagnose how this page is built
and
learn about the details so at the very
first
line of a view you get something called
a model
normally that's what you see and what is
this model
it says here we have the class called
joke so
we know that this page deals with jokes
however there's one more thing
it has a item on the outside that says i
innumerable or in other words it's a
list
so we have a list of jokes so this here
tells me
what the page is all about now when we
come down
into the code you're going to see items
that say
things like model and you're going to
have another
property there called joke answer so
what we're trying to do is just get rid
of the joke answer
so you can see that the html code is in
the format of a table
so the table header includes the joke
answer
well i'm going to take that headline out
so th stands for table head
and then the content inside is now
deleted
so also down in the for each section so
this is what generates each row in the
table
and it says here we're going to have a
joke answer let's take that out
and he's gone and then the last part
shows the edit
details and delete so let's see if that
affects any changes to our screen
okay so let's take a look here at the
jokes page and you can see
pretty quick here that we have just the
joke question
so now if i want to know the answer to
any one of these things i have to click
on the details
and then i have the full joke answer on
this page
so it's a design decision if you like
your app to work that way that's how you
modify it
so a good way then to learn how this
code is supposed to work you look at the
models that are generated by
the computer and you can see all of the
different codes
and classes and all the html that's all
done already for you
so that's a pretty quick feature that
we've just added we hid one of the
columns in our table
hey let's add another feature to this
application you can see that i have the
list of all the jokes on here when i
click
create new i have now a option that says
you have to log in
actually it's a requirement not really
an option so how do we do that
well let's see in just a second well
this is going to be incredibly easy
you'll you'll see that this is just one
line of code really
so i'm looking for the jokes controller
and i'm going for the
action called create so let's go down
and find create looks to me like about
line 61 is where it's at
so create says simply show me the view
create
we don't even want to show that part
until they've been logged in
so we're going to put in a decorator or
one of these indicators in square
brackets
and the word that we're looking for is
authorize now there is no type ahead
command here
it doesn't recognize authorize so i'm
just going to click away from it
and now i have a red line error it says
authorize
attribute is not recognized we have
potential fixes available
and it says i will recommend that you
import
this library called asp.net core
authorization let's try that
so the line should go back it's clear
now
now what happened what did we change
well up at the top of the screen
we've just imported this line on line
10.
so it says we're going to use this
library
is that all there is to it i think there
is let's run it
okay we got the app up and running let's
go ahead and choose our jokes
and we should get the list of everybody
i'll try creating a new one now
and there it is so now the login screen
says
it's it's pointed to me because as you
can see up here the registration and
login links are there i have not logged
in yet so i've already registered an
account here under email so i'll put in
shad
at jokes at app.com that's what i
registered earlier
and the password i think i put in
probably was just password1
something like that and let's go ahead
and log in
so now the login is there and we have
a registration or create page so up at
the top you can say
hello i see your name is here and you
can now create a new joke question if
you want
and then go back to the list so if i
choose create new
go straight to the create let's go back
to the list let's log out
and now let's go back and try to create
another one and it says
nobody gets to create a joke unless
you've already logged in
so that is a security so the page can't
be seen by unauthorized users
so this line here line 62 was a
just a notation that says we're not
going to do any creating form unless
you've been logged in
now the form itself has obviously
security
but the process post is following it so
we need to also put authorization here
because
this is going to actually put the data
in the database this is actually more
important for the security than the
entry form
so this this method here create is going
to be
called whenever there's a new joke to be
entered
all right what else is there let's go
down to the edit form i think we don't
want to
let anyone edit a joke unless they've
been authorized
is there any more so here is another one
that is the
processing function for an edit
edit method let's go and add authorize
there it looks to me like delete is a
good candidate for authorization
so we will take that one and then there
is a delete confirmed
i think that probably sounds like one
and then
the rest the rest one uh nothing else
okay so that looks to me like
authorization is now
in place hey let's add another feature
to our app
let's talk about css and how you can
style your page
so looking in the solution explorer i go
find this folder called www
root and expand it and you can see that
there are
html things here so we have a css folder
that has the word
site we have a javascript folder which
is also site
these two files are where you can
customize your website
now in the library folder you can see
that there are already things that are
built in here so bootstrap by default is
the styling system that we're using
that requires jquery as well and so
let's go look at site css and see what
it looks like
so you can see that there's a few css
styling commands let's
pick one of them just to illustrate that
it actually works i'm going to scroll
down
until i come to body let's just change
that to a different color
so let's try background color as an
option
and then i'm going to pick something
that is just a light gray so how about a
triple e
and i'll save that and run it okay so i
got it up and running and it looks like
i have a light
gray background i didn't have before now
if you don't see that change
it's because your browser has a style
cached in there so if you press your
shift key
and then load again it will force the
web browser or the web
server to regenerate the page it'll get
the copy from the server without using
the cache
and so if you didn't see the change that
should affect it
okay so you can see that we have a css
styling change
now css is a whole subject of its own so
this is just a crash course on asp.net
core but if you were to go and modify
things you do not go in to modify the
bootstrap
css that is all predefined for you
what they want you to do is to just work
with the site css file
which will override any of the default
bootstrap settings
the same thing goes with the javascript
you can program any page you want using
the js
file here and write your custom code so
those are your web development front end
areas that you're going to work on
so go for it if you know all that stuff
already
so there's another feature that i would
like to show you but i'm afraid we won't
have time to implement
you can see that i have added the user
column to the joke question so you can
see who the author was for these great
jokes
however i think that's going to be best
left for a more advanced video
this is pretty much a crash course on
how to build a very simple application
and we've certainly done that
so we've created a custom nav bar
we've created a table we've created
classes we've created a search function
we've integrated security we've done
some css work
there's a lot of things that we've built
here custom controllers
views and models so all of these things
are what jobs are about these days
you're going to see
interviews where this kind of technology
is a popular subject
just go in on indeed.com and check to
see how many people
are working with aspnet or dot core net
those are the key terms that you're
looking for
great jobs now many of my students that
have graduated with me have already gone
on and done some jobs with this kind of
development experience
so it's a great study and
congratulations for reaching the end of
this crash course
my name is shad slooter and i hope to
see you again in the future
you